culture à présent dans le set suite avec
les images de la finale du trophée
d'improvisation culture et diversité un
trophée qui a été lancée voici trois ans
par déclic théâtre et la fondation
culture et diversité qui agit contre
l'exclusion notamment via la culture est
jamel debbouze en est le parrain très
actif il était présent à l'espace pierre
cardin vendredi pour féliciter les
collégiens c'était à paris et il a
retrouvé un pour l'occasion un certain
alain degois papy le fondateur de la
compagnie déclic théâtre
jamel debbouze qui est retourné dans la
patinoire le lieu de l'improvisation ce
n'était pas arrivé depuis une quinzaine
d'années alors forcément l'élève n'a pas
manqué de taquiner le m regardez ce
petit extrait cette petite séquence le
plum argenté
mais pour rien qu'ils pensaient
il y avait longtemps qu'il a été pas
monté dans la patinoire est vraiment osé
faire ça c'est quand même fort vu qu'il
est aujourd'hui est de vouloir encore se
friter avec l'un proche tout ça super
beaucoup d'amitié et de respect entre
les deux hommes qui sont restés très
proches alors que la compagnie déclic
théâtre fête ses 20 ans 20 ans voici le
regard que porte djamel sur alain degois
justement c'est la personne qui m'a
permis de gagner mais arles de faire de
faire ce que je fais aujourd'hui en
toute quiétude c'est à dire il m'a filé
les outils de compréhension de ce métier
l' écoute active l'engagement enfin je
pourrais vous parler de papier une heure
mais si c'est ça c'est grâce à lui que
c'est grâce à vous que je fais ce métier
voilà ce que je veux dire la leçon que
j'ai retenue l'écoutent celle écoute ses
cours de leur principal ecoutez-le au
pouvoir créer avec lui sinon c'est pas
possible
et il écoute active que jamais n'oublie
pas ça mais ça me sert encore
aujourd'hui quand je suis costaud je
prenais que fernando meireles a pas
longtemps et je te jure que ses outils
comme affilée en impro qui servent
encore aujourd'hui je quand je ne sais
pas je j'écoute et bizarrement
bizarrement vous
j'ai fini par savoir la langue de bois
que l'on voit souvent dans les médias en
ce moment pour défendre son livre médine
trappe aux éditions quéro où il évoque
son parcours son engagement nous en
avons d'ailleurs parlé avec lui ici même
sur ce plateau vous le savez à
téléphiles qui suit depuis quasiment
l'origine la compagnie déclic théâtre
dans nos archives quelques trésors comme
ce message enregistré par un jamel très
jeune vous allez le voir qu'il
découvrait tout juste le succès le
message qu'il avait enregistré pour son
professeur louis koo de papy là d'accord
il faut que tu saches que j'étais poppy
peinture pour moi lève triste rejeté
dois tout
papy tu es mon gourou si si je peux
rendre service n'hésite pas commenter
dire maintenant que j'ai réussi je suis
dans un autre état d'esprit c'est sûr
j'ai plus besoin d'un papy et j'en ai
jamais eu besoin je vois pas qui c'est
voilà le message est clair c'était bien
évidemment pour le clin d'oeil